welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the loki episode 6 finale
leaves us
in an altered tva ruled over by jonathan
majors as he who remains a variant of
kang the conqueror but unlike the
goofball he who remains a variant this
statue
is kang the conqueror the cold-hearted
time master villain of the avengers in
the fantastic four one of those more
evil variants he who remains warned us
about maybe even the one he referred to
as a jerk which i assume is what scott
lang is gonna call kang and quantomania
coming home to a warped reality
i thought back to the future was a bunch
of [ __ ] you jerk what exactly is
going on in this final shot
like what version of the tva does loki
now find himself in and how did it get
that way well the dba timekeeper statues
being swapped out for this kang statue
does kind of parallel the ending of
planet of the apes the classic 1968
version ending with the statue of
liberty but even more similarly the 2001
tim burton remake that ended with the
altered lincoln memorial
he remains even does kind of sit the way
lincoln does in the statue
based on that you could infer that the
tva that sylvie pushed his loki back
into
was warped or rewritten due to silvi
killing he who remains
and allowing the sacred timeline to
fracture which he warned would allow
worse variants to replace him and take
the tva in an even more fascist
direction but without the cover story of
a holy trinity of time keepers just like
how marty mcfly returned to 1985 with
his timeline rewritten with his dad a
successful novelist and biff his slave
but i'm not so sure
because the mcu established back to the
future logic as
quote a bunch of [ __ ] an endgame and
loki as a series has doubled down on the
mcu timeline logic of
changes to the past cause branch
realities to split off from the sacred
timeline but
leaving that original history unaffected
which is how we get a multiverse now
sure we couldn't always trust everything
in miss minute's welcome video but he
who remains confirmed that there was a
past multiversal war
and that the mcu timeline has really
just been enjoying a period of relative
peace with occasional nexus events
creating loose variants that he who
remains via the tva has tried to prune
so when sylvie pushed loki through the
time door back into the tva
loki entered a different reality not the
tva that he spent the past several
episodes in
but a tva of a different timeline one
where mobius has no idea who loki is
one where he and b15 know their boss is
kang
where casey according to the credits is
a hunter and not necessarily a tva that
kang has invaded or conquered
but one that has always been that way
from its beginning
notice how he who remains sacred
timeline already began to fragment
even before sylvie killed him that would
imply its splitting
into a multiverse was already in the
cards and since the timeline is arranged
in a ring
it would suggest time flows in a flat
circle
in which all events are predetermined
including the eventuality that the
timeline would unravel into branches
that contain their own variant kangs
and one of those branches would contain
the tva that loki ended up in
with its tyrant flavored kang but the
confusion comes from our assumption that
the tba the void the end of time were
all
neutral ground just constants existing
separate from the sacred timeline or any
of its branches so how could this new
tva
exist within a variable timeline well it
could just be
only the citadel at the end of time that
floating rock ring
is the only neutral ground left in all
the multiverse meanwhile
every tda is linked to a specific
universe but there is another way of
interpreting this that might answer the
question because look back again at the
episode vi
opening shot we zoom out from our solar
system our galaxy
our whole known universe then it's
revealed all of that is contained within
a black hole which neighbors
another black hole that the camera now
pivots and dives into
and that is where we get he who remains
in the citadel in his sacred timeline
ring
and by this logic perhaps all the voices
and moments we
heard from the mcu past took place in a
separate universe
than the one that we spent this final
episode in and this could mean that
there is a tva for
each universe as well as infinite
citadels infinite sacred timeline rings
interestingly the only mcu voices we
hear on the way down this second black
hole
are classic loki
open your eyes open your eyes and vision
from one division what is grief if not
love persevere
but what is grief if not
love persevering a line suggested to
take place in the main mcu before civil
war but
heard during agatha and wanda's memory
trip in the west
view hex in one division suggesting hex
reality elements
like billy and tommy could exist in this
universe
which should be why wanda now hears
their voices upon the incursion but
before i continue thanks to video's
sponsor pedal and their pedal 2 card
pedal is a credit card company that
wants to help you succeed financially
the pedal 2 card was designed to help
you build credit when you apply for
pedal 2
your banking history may be used to
instantly create a cash score
a measure of your credit worthiness
based on income spending and savings it
could help you qualify even if you've
never had a credit card before pedal 2
visa card has no
annual fee you'll get one percent cash
back right away and up to 1.5
cashback when you make 12 on-time
monthly payments their app makes it easy
to track your spending make
on-time payments and manage subscription
spending pedal 2 credit limits start at
500
and range up to 10 000. see if you're
pre-approved without impacting your
credit score it takes minutes to apply
online pedal is partnered with web bank
member fdic which
issues the cards as of today the pedal 2
variable aprs range from 12.99
to 26.99 start building your credit
history go to the link in my description
box
below pedal card dot com slash new
rockstars today to find out more that's
pedal with the t
pedal p-e-t-a-l-card.com new rockstars
but i think one big clue we need to go
back and look at are those ring stains
on rinse slayer's table
she notices them again in the finale
recalling when she and mobius talked
about them back in episode two those
rings are already there
and they're all from you i think it's
from your other
favorite analyst what did that mean
well in the finale rent slayer goes from
one scene knowing nothing about he who
remains to a later scene suddenly
disturbed by whatever mystery file miss
minutes gave her but
still oddly protective of the tva's
mission and she goes through a time door
too
as she says search for free will the
information rinslayer received
might have revealed to her that this tva
was not her
first tda similar to how in the matrix
reloaded architects scene that this loki
episode seems to parallel
neo learns that this is actually the
sixth iteration of the matrix
and here now that these anomaly loki's
found a glitch in the system by falling
in love and creating an
unprecedented nexus event renslayer's
next step could be to seek out another
tva
and restart the cycle those rings on the
table could be the way the system keeps
track of what number tva they're on
two currently just like we ended a
second black hole
from the main mcu to get here and then
the sacred timeline ring
could be the second ring a ring that has
now been
broken so they must start again and in
this interpretation the sacred timeline
ring might not be a rope unraveling
branching out into several different
timelines but really a sturdy ring
breaking apart and crumbling as a
separate timeline ring representing
another universe also unravels and
tangles with it
entanglement then now has caused loki to
arrive in a tva ruled openly by kang to
conquer i know i know
this whole multiple rings interpretation
is a lot especially since one
fragmenting sacred timeline ring is
chaotic enough to wrap your head around
and now i'm suggesting it could be chaos
squared or chaos cubed and perhaps that
black hole devil's anus to devil's anus
visual might have just represented a way
to
cosmically and spatially traverse single
branch strands within
the one sacred timeline stream ring that
would be a simpler way to look at it
kind of simpler but whether the
multiverse takes the form of
intersecting capillary branches that
silvi saw after killing he who remains a
rope unraveling into different strands
or whether these are cracks in the dam
as another ring laments is into us
the conclusion is the same if kang could
have already existed in one of these
other branches
so could any of the alternate universe
marvel heroes that kang might have faced
in that alternate reality we're talking
alternate avengers
recasts of characters we knew the
fantastic four x-men
other spider people all answers that
might be coming sooner than we thought
folks and what if
no way home and multiverse of madness
comment down below with your theories
and reminder you can get our loki
inspired merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this loki out
of time shirt
all of them directly support us here at
new rockstars follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you